I I'm curious because at your Peak as an
artist when you're extremely active you
were like the go-to hookman right
everybody had to have an acon hook you
had you gave people careers there was
people who was getting deals or getting
bags just because they had you on a hook
right
um what was the biggest bag you got to
do a hook
um well actually mine when it come to
hook bags it was a little different
because every song you ever heard me on
that half the hook on it was a record I
produced so I would give them the beat
with me already on the chorus so they
had to pay for both they had to pay for
the whole thing so like because there's
been a lot of um artists who have done
songs that like clearly they did for the
bag was there one of those for you where
you were like yo this bag was so crazy
the song might have been I might not
have loved the artist but the song it
was bad you know what's interesting
in the beginning there was one record
that I can recall started with a bag and
then I was so happy I did it because the
relationship came out it was amazing it
was Baby Bash oh I love that record you
know that because I at before I did that
record I had never heard a big bash baby
I'm back man yeah baby I'm back I never
heard that song and it was interesting
because once I was like okay cool this
is some good money so I did it but then
when I met him we connected I was like
damn glad I did this record baby he's
such a cool dude he's like the coolest
guy ever coolest dude in the [ __ ]
world yeah so I was like man I'm so
happy we connected this way you know
then I felt bad because I was like if
I'd known this I would never charge them
yeah it's crazy because at that time you
probably aren't hip to what he's doing
right you know the Latin world is so
different it was so different first
major label debut right you know he came
off that Frankie J record right yeah
Cyclone Baby I'm back yeah yeah he
tapped in with convict music for sure
for that first hour you know because
right after that we send them over to
T-Pain and got another record yeah